e aí galera se tiver cuidado você acha
que entretenimento testou essa semana de
canal incluindo gente não podes do deixe
o canal morreu assim é bom eu eu parei
disse bem pouco televisão eu acho legal
assim às vezes é que repete muitas
coisas eo record todo mundo odeia o
chris sbt achar globo e lagoa azul e
isso me incomoda às vezes que é a mesma
coisa devia trocar nem como tirar todo
mundo dela azul lá quando criei chaves
azul sei lá uma coisa diferente eu acho
engraçado em televisão é a propaganda de
televisão propaganda eleitoral então
temos a nossa programação para a
proibição do horário eleitoral gratuito
horário eleitoral gratuito aí eu paro e
penso é claro que é gratuito e já fui a
pessoa no mundo que engarrafa e
televisão é tv a cabo é completa ou
assinatura sportv é fc eo big brother se
chama de prova horário eleitoral
gratuito o prefeito dudu que não
ficassem viu a propaganda dilma é doida
não existe essa pessoa o horário
eleitoral ele passa tipo em todos os
canais só que tem uns dois ou três que
não passa a cair beleza vou assistir o
que não era eleitoral muda neste governo
eu vou realizar várias reformas muda
neste governo
eu vou realizar valor neste governo eu
vou realizar moura neste governo
eu vou toda neste governo muda neste
confuso com a lei angolana que vai ter
mais e mais memória e 49 mas é mais 20
mil ou vídeo de ambiente olha que só vai
você acompanha no canal do boi que não
está passando o horário eleitoral é o
canal do boi não ficou então boi parado
lá todos cartagena e eo boi traga bosta
estrumes é pra ver bosta
vou botar no horário eleitoral - agora
eu acho engraçado é comercial de creme
país pinho porque não comercial de campo
a espanha nunca tem uma pessoa que tem
espinha tipo e buscava chamar eu vou
começar o país porque ele sabe que não
dá jeito ele bota quem o luan santana
luan santana vai fazer um comercial para
isso lança luz entrando têm espiritual
luan santana era o espelho lindo aquele
cabelo maravilhoso aquela pele
maravilhosa estava no seu rosto quando
ele vira pra cá é um espião é do tamanho
de um abacate e ele fala todo dia tenho
que acordar bem bonita para fazer um
show
ele pega o sabor e ana vai joney bay na
mente em tirou sabonete cadeia espinha
sumiu na hora mas todo mundo sabe que
espanha não sou na hora porque sumiu na
hora porque não tinha espinha o luan
santana não tem a espinha se recusa a
sair na cara do lanço tanto a espanha
vai na cela farah na nossa tá não tá
adorando aí vamos aceitar mudanças vão
nascer na cara do windows a nossa aqui
outro comercial com a china graçado é de
creme dental creme estava sempre tipo
assim em dois adolescentes sentado num
sofá branco do adolescente lindo
não vou dizer a verdade não é feio não
viu é lindo estou de tênis não só faz
sobre itens no sofá se fosse a minha
casa primeiro que tênis em cima do sofá
certeza eu sei precisar mas nunca
escovar os dentes porque eu ia morrer
ali a minha mãe ia me matar certeza
ainda comercial estão usando acidente de
trem em cima do sofá estão jogando [ __ ]
play 618 estou há 15 dias vai falar
assim papai eu fui comer uma maçã e
saiba esse negócio vermelho aqui em
papel comercial sérgio marone nossa isso
pode ser gente evite que causa mau
hálito félix que meu pai d'égua para
moderar massa ficou toda coisa aqui ó
se começar porque o que é ser bom já
estava aqui dentro o pai do comercial
não possui leva os filhos vai vai todo
mundo e todo mundo ficava doente juntos
o lindo né e gostoso isso é mentira todo
mundo sabe que escovar junto não dá
certo o fixo salvando o outro estava
também fica aquela dúvida quem é que vai
lá vai com o primeiro é que vai cuspir
primeiro não vou lavar meu irmão começa
a amar mão o outro sem vontade com o
hospital o cope na mão dura verde pv e
boca namorada jenny ficar demorando
navarro lavabo continha gostou demais
espumou começa a escorrer pela que cai
na blusa zaga sai daí 4 começa a bater
não dá certo propaganda de hyogo se que
regula o intestino se o seu intestino
não funcionar a gente levando o seu
dinheiro é lógico que eu do carro ao
supermercado com latinhas é rapaz estava
aqui no meu direito um cargueiro não
nunca você nunca encontrou uma pessoa na
rua que aí reparei vai tá aí pra onde eu
aposto em um supermercado levar a compra
não vou trocar sua batuta que eu comprei
pra dar um jeito no meu cuido deus é seu
intestino vai funcionar como um
reloginho no relógio e quem tenha
morrido é o que é relógio b10 permuta
mas sabão em pó menino correndo
braga a lama ea mãe sorrindo olha que
coisa linda
ah meu filho corre na musa tão branca
tinha um ou vários preta e azul laden
mike ficou recoberto eu vou deixar a
minha mãe não deixe não porque não dá pé
não existe lama não saiu da casa e não
chegou a sair da casa não chegou a sair
do quarto e não chegou a sair do banho e
botou a blusa branca ela manda tinha
traçado que a merda vai acontecer a
qualquer momento comercial na janela meu
filho vai demandar traz outras ainda meu
filho nessa ilusão braga
a claro ainda abbottabad em pó depois
passa a ficar aquela animação zinha
sujeito vai sair aí minha mãe cada
gotinha de lama é um xingamento ela lava
que essa desgraça só serve para sujar
estamos 70 empregado ao tamanho olha o
tamanho da mancha hoje eu e mais
comercial e cantaremos se você tiver
gostar desse vídeo clipe gostei aqui no
youtube comenta aqui embaixo que você
acha mais estranho mais bizarro nas
propagandas de televisão volta lá no
facebook eu falei vídeo novo disse que
lá não tinha postado no facebook marca
seus amigos lá nos comentários do
facebook você acha que também acho essas
mesmas coisas de propaganda que eu acho
o ano nem é que acho que eu acho que eu
não acho que a equipe pode se sacode
quem não pode perder paulo
muito obrigado se inscreve o grupo nunca
perdeu um vídeo novo é nóis valeu e
parou e eu vou comer até com fome